hey what is up guys I'm kV HD here and
this is the LG g3 and it has a quad HD
display which means it's rocking a 2560
by 1440 resolution if your mind isn't
blown yet let me give you some
perspective let me take you back a few
years to the iPhone 3GS
this was Apple's flagship in 2009 and it
had a three-and-a-half inch display at a
resolution of 320 by 480 giving it a
pixel density of 165 pixels per inch and
it looked pretty good it looked decently
sharp and Apple thought it was good but
the next year Apple released the iPhone
4 and one of its biggest named features
which took its name dropped all the time
now is the retina display it's the
highest resolution display ever built
into a phone at 326 pixels per inch you
get four times the pixels as before so
instead of the fuzziness of individual
pixels you get smooth continuous shapes
and tone you have something that looks
to your eye like you're holding a
printed page in your hand and the level
of fine detail and images is just
incredible so the iPhone 4 they are
talking about still has a
three-and-a-half inch display but now
has a resolution of 640 by 960 which
gives it a pixel density of 326 pixels
per inch so at that point figure that's
the size we're going to go right like
that's as much as we need anything north
of 300 pixels per inch is so sharp that
you literally cannot see fuzzyness you
cannot discern individual pixels on the
display at a normal viewing distance or
even at a super close viewing distance
but no of course we didn't stop there
we've since then gotten 1280 by 720
displays 1920 by 1080 displays and now
panels 2560 by 1440 in a smart phone
obviously it's much bigger it's a 5.5
inch screen now but the sharpness at
over 500 PPI is crazy but if everything
north of 300 pixels per inch is the same
then why even bother with quad HD why
would you I mean surely it's going to
hit battery life right it's going to
stress your graphics extra it might kind
of disturb the performance of the phone
well I hope to find out exactly
how much this phone's display affects
its performance in the full review so
make sure you subscribe to the channel
if you haven't already to see that full
review when it comes out that button is
below somewhere it's red but until then
this video just going to be taking a
look at the quality difference to see if
there's really difference between this
quad HD display and some others so go
ahead and use the gear in the bottom
right hand corner of the video to change
this to 4k or 1440p or whatever highest
resolution you can watch it in and
fullscreen it because even if you don't
have a 4k display YouTube streams these
high resolution videos at higher bit
rates so the clarity is improved anyway
so here is the new OS 10 Yosemite 5k
wallpaper it's a really high resolution
higher than any other display I have and
here is that wallpaper on the iPhone 5s
so it's a 4-inch display at 326 pixels
per inch and you can see it looks pretty
good it's pretty crisp and from a
regular viewing distance there are
absolutely no problems and like we said
Apple has boasted about this 326 pixels
per inch a lot and that's what they call
a Retina display so now here it is on
the HTC One m8 this is a much larger
5-inch display coming in at 1920 by 1080
which gives it a pixel density of 441
pixels per inch and it seems like a
noticeable improvement actually which
most would say you know it's crystal
clear you know not a pixel in sight a
little bit better and probably more
enjoyable of a viewing experience
because of the larger display but again
this is 441 pixels per inch and lastly
here it is on the lg g3 which like we've
said is a new 5.5 inch quad HD display
coming in at 534 pixels per inch and I
mean come on that's ridiculously sharp
and whether or not you can see it though
technically yes there is actually a
difference in clarity only because we're
using an image here that's of a high
enough resolution
here's another super high-res image on
all three displays and I got to say
while they all look great you really
couldn't tell the difference unless
you're holding them side-by-side or
comparing them of course there are other
things that make a good display like
color accuracy and viewing angles and
obviously the size of the panel that
does elapsed around it and there's a ton
of stuff like goes into making a good
smartphone display but really the bottom
line here is that it's actually kind of
hard to tell the difference between quad
HD and even 1080p unless you're looking
for the difference or holding them up
side-by-side like we have in this 4k
video and since every app on your phone
is basically scaled to 1080p right now
you're not going to notice much of the
benefits or advantages of having the
super high res display for now I mean
text will definitely be sharper and
wallpapers will look awesome and all of
LG's assets like I've said their icons
are great but third party stuff I mean
their icons still aren't super high
resolution and apps don't really take
advantage of all those extra pixels yet
the YouTube app on Android still only
streams at a highest quality of 720p not
even 1080p so really the benefits are
limited but like I said that's for now
it makes a much bigger difference on
bigger panels like computer monitors and
TVs to have that higher resolution but
that doesn't mean I don't appreciate a
baller display in a smartphone and while
it's not necessarily worth it now it
sure will be in maybe one or two years
when every smartphone is quite HD so
there you go that's what it looks like
to have the quad HD display on the LG g3
again the full review of this phone is
in the works as I put it through its
paces so that's coming soon enough and I
can't wait to show you guys the other
stuff I'm working on too so thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one bass